um thank you sir um I thank the
organizers to for organizing this
workshop I got a lot out of it and some
of what I've learned is actually
reflected in the talk in the slides
that's one of the advantage of being the
anchor speakers you can sort of
adaptively change your talk as the week
goes on so joint work with you guang GAO
who is a PhD student excuse me PhD
student at Cornell that I'm working with
and okay I wouldn't get channel coding
so it's a bit different from some of the
prior talks but there's a significant
learning component to what we're looking
at specific how much learning you have
to do in order to communicate at
capacity over a channel okay so that's
the question maybe I should declare the
outset they don't really have like a
completely conclusive answer to this
question I'll declare that now it's
helpful if your expectations are kind of
low when we as we move on and so keep
that in mind okay so let's start start
with the basics I'm sure how fast to go
through this so I'll go kind of fast and
you can please stop me if you have
questions about this look kind of basic
Shannon theory communication set up so
when I say channel in this talk I mean
throughout what we call discrete
memoryless channel this is basically
stochastic matrix like from one alphabet
X to an elf about why and we think this
is like a model of a channel so each
time you can input a symbol from X and
the output is random and distribution is
the row of the matrix corresponding to
the input X okay and you use this
channel many times so we're going to
communicate over it so we have an end
coder that would take a string of n bits
it would map it to a string of n X
symbols this channel would produce a
random string of outputs according to
this matrix and given X the string is
independent over time that's the
memoryless part and then you have a
design a decoder that takes the Y string
and then tries to recover the it's okay
so that's the setup and the classic
theorem in this in this business is that
the for such a channel you can define a
capacity which is the largest rate R for
which this error probability the m10
error probably will go to 0 as n goes to
infinity and for most interesting
channels it seems positive and you can
kind of compute it explicitly as the
maximum visual information through the
socratic matrix okay so this is very
classical stuff it's also classically
if you allow perfect feedback to the end
quarters so sort of sees the outputs of
the channel kind of causally as they
come out and adapt that you can't
achieve higher rates and throughout the
talk we're going to assume we have this
feedback link here that's kind of
important okay so we'll assume I mean
obviously you know real feedback is sort
of not ideal like this but will this is
the model will have ideal feedback like
this okay so that's for a known channel
right one channel in real life you don't
know the channel going in you've got to
somehow learn it adapt to it make do
with some uncertainty so what we say
about unknown channels and one of the
things I've learned from this week long
workshop is that I should view
everything as a minimax problem so here
is channel coding as a minimax problem
okay so fix the input alphabet fix the
output alphabet fix the rate some fudge
factor some back off epsilon ok you can
strengthen the previous theorem as
follow so you can find one code for each
block length whose rate is at least our
minus your back off ok so that the error
probability of that code over any
channel when you maximize over all
channels between these alphabets whose
capacity is at least are certain kind of
support the rate that you're targeting
ok this quantity here will tend to 0 as
n goes to infinity ok so you can sort of
drive the error probability 20 uniformly
over all channels connecting these two
alphabets as long as the capacities on
the Shannon capacity in the previous in
a sense the previous slide exceeds the
the rate that you're targeting you know
minus of course there's some little gap
there right ok so I mean this is the you
can find this proven in the literature
the first reference i could find
actually white recent i think the result
was kind of known you know kind of as a
folk theorem prior to that and the proof
is very simple I mean you just sort of
allocate some vanishing fraction of your
block to trainings who just sort of
probe each input see what happens
estimate the channel and then proceed as
though your estimate was exactly right
and just you just use that for the rest
of the block ok so that's the scheme
that that proves this this result ok so
sorry yes this is what this is
absolutely with feedback the feedback is
really important here those you can't
learn the input distribution yeah so you
need the any of the feedback yeah and
there are some of these here about
whether you want you allow randomized
coders or not you know when there's just
one channel it's easy to do randomized
we have multiple not so simple but
anyway okay so yeah ng node of you know
no that's that's that be the debbie the
next min right that beasts up in yeah
they're unknown yeah that's that's the
that's the crucial statement here you
can find one code for each block length
that kind of handles all the channels in
this set okay so you know this is this
theorem is like such an established part
of the Canon of the field that I feel
entitled to bash it a little bit okay so
one thing i don't like about this
theorem is that it really relies the
proof you'll realize very crucially on
the fact that learning the channel is
absolutely free okay you pay a peasant I
to keep a no cost for learning the
channel okay so there's no penalty for
not knowing it right this is not
realistic in my view all right yeah but
I mean if the channel is the capacity
was kind of below the rate I wanted even
if I knew it I couldn't work with it
right so in some sense it seems like no
penalty at all for not knowing it okay
and moreover you don't have to be very
smart about how you learn the channel
writing this in the scheme here I mean
he's very naive schemes to learn the
channel it's fine you can be very very
kind of lazy or course in your learning
of the channel and this is not realistic
right in real life you don't know the
channel you got to learn it and then the
learning process is important it has a
non-trivial cost you want to minimize
that people work very hard to try to
dream up ways of kind of minimizing the
cost of training of learning the channel
at the beginning and that's just
completely lost in this result okay so
the questions how do you modify the
model to kind of capture that cost okay
there are few ways of doing it you could
just for fixed parameters here you can
study the speed of convergence and
compare that to the the this up in you
know statement and I study schemes that
do that and you know there's chocolate
and tell it or work and essentially that
that problem I think is very good so the
reports we're taking a little bit
different and maybe more than the theme
of this workshop which is we're gonna
study the speed of convergence here is a
function of the alphabet sizes okay so
you know here the other it's fixed
completely you could ask how is I start
varying the size of these alphabets how
does the speed of this
it change you sort of spec to slow down
as the alphabets increase right you're
taking supreme over a bigger set in
terms of the proof it takes longer to
learn the channel the larger these
alphabets are so you expect to slow down
and can you kind of quantify that slow
down and then maybe quantifying that
what kind of force you to come up with
clever training schemes that's the
program here finite fixed X and y yes
finite all the alphabets in here are
finite another global assumption yes
David combination right because
sometimes the X could be a
discretization of the continuous base in
RP for a second so you mean this this
theorem right here you think is not
formulation or what am I change our
launch much NB yeah x is a discrete
alphabet but it's a quantization of my
underlying continuous alphabet so you
increase n somehow the public should not
become more difficult true yeah so so a
sensor is saying I mean the real chance
we care about our sort of intrinsically
continuous so why would we use these
discrete models yeah so that's you could
certainly formulate it differently with
but these sort of continuous forms and
we're sort of following the the
traditional information theory approach
is starting with the mcs and figuring it
out first and then looking at you know
how it extends to continuous channels
but you're right i mean that's I mean in
a sense the DMC is that we're going to
be studying they're going to come up you
know that that comes to achieve the
supremum are not really have a lot of
structure across the rows where you spec
to have that structure in if this is
like a quantized version of a the
continuous channel so you're right ya
know what's dependents are like the
Lipschitz constant of your continuously
I think you can give me the outfit sizes
therefore any
yeah that would be different formulation
well ya know it's essentially the same
right nice trip if you have a rather non
Lipschitz function then when you disc
your diet is presumably you're going to
take more chunks but so I mean either
maybe there's a natural I like better
than my previous one may not be better
than Greg's but there's better than mine
is I mean so I mean in the other square
channel you can just sort of asked like
how fast is the convergence here is a
function of how many parameters are in
the the channel law right you don't know
the channel law it's in some family it's
parametrized by some family to sort
number parameters you don't know that
you sort of need to learn if you want to
use this approach and how does how does
this what does the speed of his
convergence as a function of how many
parameters there are and the ass we're
starting with this model is sort of a
simple model here the number of
parameters is like the product size ok
if you consider other richer more
complicated channel models that premise
write it differently yeah so you see how
large and should be on should end of 10
so that's this is trying to be in you
feel the functional fits a live in exit
10 yeah it was fun playing ok so this
this is not intended to be like you know
this is intend to be like a very
informal lead into this one right here
ok all right ok so yeah I mean
ultimately you'd like to I me ideally
certified for a fixed end for fixed
alphabet sites here here radar you'd
sort of characterize like this in sup
right ok but we like to that's hard to
do we're going to back off and
characterize something relatively coarse
actually which is just just for what
alphabet speeds is the limit 0 and 4
which is it not ok so say a secret a
pair of alphabets X&Y support universal
communication if reverie back off
reverie rate then the limit continues to
be 0 even now when you're taking Supreme
not over alphabets from a fixed alphabet
but for X and you know when used block
length n when your quotas walking and
supreme was taken over the alphabets xn
and yn ok so these alphabets are
potentially growing with n ok so as
you're blocking increases you have sort
of more time to communicate but you have
more to learn if you're using a
learning-based scheme so it's not really
clear how this would play out certainly
if the alphabets are fixed I'm if you
just choose all these to be the same
with n this reduces to sort of the
previous result and
our and changes okay that's true yeah
your point that's not a big advance but
yeah that's your right that's very true
and since our varies we allow
multiplicative back off in addition to
gotta show you have a multiplicative
back off and additive back off when I
was growing okay so the question is how
fast the alphabets grow with ends that
this is still true the obvious go really
fast then you may expect that the
convergence is going to slow down so
much that it just doesn't convert
anymore 20 all right so there's
certainly connections to the sort of
lossless compression version of this
story studied by various people who are
here Ilan and Stefan we heard about this
earlier this week and Wake Tech and
marchello and so on this problem I think
is that it's a bit more complicated for
starters we have to alphabets rather
than one right I mean it's or supporting
you know just the source alphabet here
you have x and y and it's not clear i
probably how interchangeable these
alphabets are right like a big axe in a
small y versus a big wine a small axe
it's not clear which is harder okay so
what can you do so okay so having
formulated rather coarse damn you're not
going to course in it even more so let's
just look at powers so assume that the
alphabet input alphabet goes under the
Alpha I'll put his end of the beta and
we'll study for what alpha and beta is
this limit equals zero okay so it's I
mean this is a very coarse formulation
but this is what we can talk about okay
so let's start with a training scheme
this came in to learn the channel first
and then communicates based on what is
learned so the sort of you know
classical proofs that that work for a
fixed alphabet kind of break down
quickly when the alphabet starts growing
but if you just keep the scheme the same
at least keep the same kind of
philosophical scheme and just sort of
push the analysis or do a balance is
kind of more refined and more delicately
then you can show that as long as the
product size Rose sub linearly then
you're okay and this is maybe not
unexpected because that the total number
of parameters in your distribution in
some sense right so I'm if it takes like
you know ends and tries roughly to learn
a distribution from nelle flute of size
n you know here this is like the number
of unknown parameters in your matrix so
it's kind of roughly what you trying to
your question okay every alpha plus beta
listen sorry for every right with
something I'm sorry yeah so yeah I
should just say there should be no for
all just if that's true I'm sorry yeah
yeah I change the slide at the last
minute and I think I botched it up yeah
this is he phenom leave no no this is
one particular scheme works if this
condition holds right here so we'll get
to the only if right now actually so
okay so for what comes later it's
helpful to plot this okay so here's
alpha ears beta so the scheme handles
this regime right here and there's a
questions this is optimal it's like
training then yeah yeah so the only non
trivial thing is kind of analyzing how
fast alphabetic growth rate in here okay
so this is certainly optimal if he was
just on learning the channel so you can
study a separate problem or you should
forget communication and just ask like
given the alphabet growth rates can you
learn the channel or not by the end of
the block length okay and and that you
can show at least you know did this
setup is exactly this region here it was
maybe not surprising the outside noting
its kind of subtle in establishing that
is that you don't constrain how many
times the encoder uses each input you
just constrain the total amount of time
it can allocate time among the inputs
however it wants so the time it spends
on one really ok ok so the time it
spends on one input you know could be
very good sample path dependent right so
it's a bit subtle there so anyway so the
question is if you wanted establishes
this optimal the question is do you I
mean step seeing whether it's optimal or
not is sort of 10 them up to determining
whether you have to learn the channel in
order to communicate at capacity right
and when we get we began this I was very
hopeful that you would not need to learn
the channel because if you look at the
training based scheme first of all the
Angkar does not need to know the whole
matrix it only is know that capacity
cheating input distribution which is a
much lower dimensional object so it's
not going to fill in the hole w to
figure out this argh min and the décor
doesn't use the train at all actually in
the proof ok so there is some hope that
you'd be able to come up with more
clever schemes that kind of entertain
out here but we have three of
possibility results that say in various
directions you try to
move you can't do it and so I'll show
you them sort of increasing order of
increasing difficulties first off the
input grow super linearly so it's not
going to work so this region's out and
that's kind of obvious I mean requires a
proof but essentially if you know if you
pick rose I could have linear or
superlinear go super lean you can even
touch all the inputs once over the
course of the block so there's no way
you can communicate that capacity right
guy to these touch test each input once
and see what happens that's pretty clear
okay the others flip side where the
output grows linearly or super linearly
is a little bit more interesting and let
me say a few words about that so so for
this research took the minimax lower
bounding techniques from from statistics
and sort of channeled them so to speak
and me are you know our risk function
you're going to call it that's kind of
complicated so it's not a direct
application we can sort of apply some
similar ideas so consider this channel
so two inputs you stand here so two
inputs like zero and one and you've end
of the beta outputs if your sin 0 it's
uniform over this set there send one
your from over that set right ok so the
capacity is clearly one bit this is
essentially like an identity matrix you
can coalesce these these symbols let's
cheat by uniform input all right now
it's the w NB the set of all channels
obtained via column permutations of this
they all have the same capacity
apparently all right and then consider
the block mixture channel like this ok
so given the input you pick a channel
out of this class you're familiar random
and then you apply that end times
generate the output I said you're hard
to show that if these alphabets
supported universal communication ok
then you be able to find a code that
operated it rate log 2 and over this
channel with a vanishing error
probability roughly you can achieve log
2 over each channel in the class and the
error probability of the mixture is a
mixture of the error probabilities so if
you're probably low for each town the
class it's going to be low for the
mixture ok but you can show the capacity
of this mixture channels got to be quite
a bit lower ok the argument there is as
follows so in certain mutual information
of the challenge the message is the
output to entropy this might be the
first entropy decomposition we've seen
all week right had to happen eventually
so here we are okay can everyone the
entry the output through a uniform
distribution look at mr.
here is really the critical one okay so
think about the different terms in this
some start which is the first one
entropy of y1 given em what's the
distribution of Y 1 given em right well
it was like the first input you're
sending right so when you send the first
input you know nothing about the channel
all calm you tations are equally likely
so all the outputs are equally likely at
that stage right no outputs more likely
than another so the entropy of y1 given
M is log into the beta that cancels one
of these and the betas likewise next
step sufficient of white too given this
stuff I mean depends on whether you send
you know the same input twice or two
different inputs suppose you send the
same input twice okay the dispersion of
y2 given that information will look like
as follow so one of the inputs will been
revealed by the previous time step but
because the column permutations are all
equally likely then all the rest of them
are the same so this essentially uniform
distribution oversized alphabet size end
of the beta so it's again like logged
end of the beta and cancels one of these
okay the point is mu can keep doing this
and as long as you're looking at the
index it's much lower than the output
alphabet size then distribution of Y I
given the message in the past would be
roughly uniform and so you'll get log
into the beta and in that regime you end
up back with a capacity like zero for
this mixture channel okay so that's not
going to work okay so no court can
achieve capacity for all channels in
this class and I think what's
interesting about this is that you know
the optimum input distribution is no
mystery here it's uniform for every
channel in the class so it's not a
matter of learning the optimum put
distribution it's more the decoder can't
really make sense at the output without
a lot of training that's really what's
going on okay so that's that am i doing
oh okay all right so so here's the slow
down then here's the last of the three
results so let me show you the picture
actually so this is what we had before
so this is result number three so
essentially what happens is we can show
you know if you can show any point is
infeasible then everything that
dominates it also is also infeasible
right so essentially what we show is
that like everything on this line here
isn't feasible this is the kind of
points where alpha plus beta equals one
and where the output alphabet is bigger
than the input alphabet okay so I'll
just say a few words about this let me
kind of just explain the square point
the square root n square root n and
these ones are kind of similar well
maybe say a few words about that if I
can okay so suppose the matrix organic
matrix that's unknown is square and we
again generate a class that's sort of
hard to communicate over and i'll turn
the classes file is put half on the
diagonal okay so that's just their
deterministically and then i'll pick
some number of gamma less than half less
than the power here and then we'll
generate will randomly pick n to the
gamma entries in each row now just paint
them with Abu square like this so can
you put probability you know put the
remain pal Billy uniformly over those
squares okay so so you did for each row
and you get suggesting matrix like that
ok that's a randomly generated matrix in
the class all right so you can work out
the capacity of a typical realization of
a channel in this class it's kind of
standard stuff part of the row entropy
is deterministic right the entry of each
row is the same doesn't matter where you
put the blue boxes so that the you know
the capacity is random only to extent
that this the entropy of the output kind
of depends on what input dispersion your
use and so on but it's roughly a uniform
input will give uniform output so you
work out kind with the nominal capacity
is for each channel in the class and
since it's essentially achieved by
uniform input ok so then the point is if
you take pic bit near the block mixture
version of all the channels in this
class you can again show that if you
could achieve capacity for every channel
in the class you achieve the same
capacity the same rate mixture channel
and by assuming reasoning to the
previous result you can show you can't
do that essentially because the decoder
has to learn the positions of all these
things in order to make sense of the the
output all right and positioned about
this case is you know in the previous
case it couldn't really do it for either
the early to Rose right in a previous
case the decoder print learn either row
they didn't have enough time here it's
always square root of n across right so
so the code could learn some rows very
well if it wanted it to because we learn
makeup too
Rose roughly so we can learn some rose
really well but it can't run all of them
and that's kind of the key thing here
and that's specially why we have these
halves and the diagonal so when you
first started we have the halves we just
did the blue thing thinking that would
be enough trying to mimic you know the
previous result and it didn't work and
the reason it didn't work is that if you
just have the blue things it's possible
for the for the code to kind of the
encoder think of it just guess our
trying rose and learning rose and
eventually it can find a subset of rose
that over which a uniform input gives
you a uniform output and once it has
that doesn't need the rest of the Rose
at that point it can just use that
smaller set of rows to achieve capacity
so it doesn't have to learn everything
and that sort of defeats the purpose of
the converse proof right so so one of
you belong as many contributions to this
was to the complicated putting the
halves on the diagonal and we do that
you sort of force the the end quarter to
use all the inputs like it can't there's
no hope of achieving capacity if you
don't use all the inputs and if you use
all the inputs then you've got to learn
them kind of by the reasoning of the
previous result and so that's that's it
okay so that's kind of where we stand
just for comparison purposes so zest you
know what happens if you do the reverse
so suppose you can form the same way as
before suppose you just swap the this up
in the IMP okay so now the code can
depend on the channel but you still
require the convergence of the error
probably to be uniform over all channels
in the class okay so for this we can
give a much more conclusive answer it
was very different as you can show the
alphabets will allow this okay if their
growth rate satisfies this condition
okay so it's a couple of striking things
about this so first of all the product
alphabet size doesn't matter anymore so
the minimum it's not even the maximum
actually it's the minimum of the two
alphabets okay and they can grow really
fast so as long as some sense as long as
either one alphabet or the either grows
is like e to the square root of n or
slower and slower than either the square
root of n then you're okay
need to restrict the Alpha this at all
well I mean I mean the capacity term is
sort of based on concentration results
right if the alphabet square really fast
then you well I mean we have some
condition here yeah you have some
condition yeah yeah all right anyway I
mean the upshot that the upside take
away from this is that the the knowing
the channel buys you a lot let me go
from kind of like linear growth rate the
alphabets an end to like you the square
root of n for one of the alphabet so it
begs a big jump so it certainly the
model is capturing like the cost of
learning the channel in some sense so
it's a success in that regard so must
one learn the channel so and we don't
know is the short answer but I mean it
appears so in a sense that you know all
this is blocked out we don't know what's
happening here the reason this is harder
than over here is that so when the input
alphabet size is smaller than the output
alphabet size sorry is going to be
around when the input is bigger than the
output then even when the channel is
known you can show that there there
always exists a subset of inputs there's
no larger than the number of outputs so
that the code can just use those inputs
so the code you know when it knows the
channel doesn't need to use all the
inputs can use a subset of them and so
naturally it's kind of harder to force
the encoder to have to learn everything
and your sins have to kind of
constructive channel with you know good
rose and bad rose and the big woodrows
are very few and they're inland
locations and it's sort of hard to tell
a good roll from the bad roll without
learning the whole row but the same time
you can't allow that you don't want the
end quarter to allow the end quarter to
communicate using bad rose I could have
to has to use the good road she has to
find them so that's sort of the one
needs to be done to fill that fill that
in and they're certainly connections to
like the the impossibility results for
learning the entropy because it's like
how good a row is is kind of tied up
with its row entropy if you think about
the mutual formation decomposition right
but it's more complicated that because
the output distribution matters as well
okay so I mean even if you know this
turns out to be yellow or whatever color
this is so that it's that all seems
negative then I'm certainly were
ignoring the sub polynomial
actors so there's some hope and I guess
here we showed if you have exactly
linear growth you can't do it exactly
when your growth can't do it it's
conceivable that maybe something in the
middle here would allow wiener growth
and then it's related David's question
at the beginning so I mean this is it's
it's really a very pessimistic channel
model and it's also a little bit weird
admittedly in that you know we fix the
alphabet church the capacity and the
channel could be anything in that class
so it's a great big class as we've seen
a lot of weird channels in that class so
even if you know these results are
pessimistic perhaps if you sort of
restrict the class of channels to some
smaller more structured class some of
what's defined was talking about in his
store scoring talk on Wednesday I think
it was you know perhaps then it's you
wouldn't need lock links that are quite
so large as a function of the alphabet
size would be yes could be although
perhaps some classes though would be
such that you don't necessarily do learn
all the parameters here you do in some
sense going all they unknown parameters
to communicate but perhaps with other
classes you wouldn't have to do that
that's all thank you
I want this yeah so here you're
considering the polynomial scaling into
that van to the vitalife isn't hiding
some log factor for example which we saw
in the entropy case I hope so yeah I
mean we don't know I mean so in a sense
what's what's happening kind of right at
right at the boundary and some sense ya
never know laundry yeah so let me say
this so what we showed is if alpha plus
beta is strictly bigger than one okay
then you can't do it that's the way here
here we sort of alpha equals one can't
do it so there's no longer a factor
hiding there that the no no no log
method factor to our benefit you know
that right likewise here so it's
possible in the middle maybe something
weird happens yes pretty pessimistic but
is there any hope of there being a bit
of magic doing simple that you feel like
yeah you can just all you want to do is
find a couple of weeks ago yeah lots of
them you know they exist all right
what's right to make you a question up
here ticularly is a pessimistic about
the well I think it's I mean it's some
of its just psychological I mean I
started thinking you know and then the
more and more kind of got blocked off I
guess it's pot you know if this at this
point here wasn't you know here if we
have linear growth in the input alphabet
and like you can't do it was it sort of
obvious right so now I guess it's
conceivable that like you know you move
just like slightly in and then suddenly
good things happen but I don't know it
seemed a little bit surprising
Anna do you want to be I'm gonna take
over the department the session shares
job and just call people yeah I'm you
arranged the chance fight yeah okay you
have the channel is known oh the second
yeah okay kind of the probability of
error should fill uniformly 20 right
yeah here suppose I told you choose
channels if you knew them this happened
to their channels that have a very large
alphabet but take you to have the
probably very go very slowly yeah look
at you you essentially yeah what's you
logistic then you can find the challenge
what that's what yeah you can find such
channel deal yeah there's no learning
here that's right exactly but in this
sort of sets the baseline like if the
North winning was not an issue than how
what could you do so it shows that you
know the learning is a sense costing you
a lot in a previous resolved it was no
learning then it jumps up to this
yep I'm very chill no yeah right yeah
bat me a sense so I mean one way of
trying to you know model that would be
to say like you know you don't you can't
use the channel very many times before
changes so kind of look at one block at
a time now and you're in if you want to
call the learning limited regime you
know we don't have enough samples to
really learn effectively and how well
can you do and this asymptote is
sometimes trying to capture that I mean
if I'm looking ok i lost my plot but if
i'm looking in the in here then I mean
this is sort of like the capturing the
winning limited regime is an asymptotic
sense ok but it'sit's qualitatively he's
trying to capture the same notion yeah
look at this picture right suppose that
the encoder doesn't know the channel
yeah it does ok wait how does this
picture change good question I don't
know so you're negative all your counter
your negative results when you put this
mission is known like you know it does
it presumably the field well here it is
on the end quarter not knowing what to
do so wait you prove this is you have a
yeah up there up there yeah the encoder
node decoder knew then there are pooper
totally break down so it's very possible
that that would that would change things
and we looked at the the source quoted
version of that lossless compression and
look at the situation where you know
neither the anchor know the decoder know
the source exactly and the one where
both know it exactly and one with the
decoder knows it exactly and the
vacations decor knows it exactly sort of
something equivalent to when they both
know so for lossless compression at
least you know just putting the
information of the decoder is sort of
enough the inquiry which kind of
randomly bin and then the decoder can
sort of figure out from what it knows
and that's that's fine it's really there
it makes a big difference here yeah I
don't know
Shankar